jackass is so loved and what people
always say about it is you know the how
the the camaraderie between all the guys
just really reads you know you can tell
that everybody says you can tell you
guys just love each other so much and
that's what makes it work this great
chemistry and I I don't disagree with
that at all but like I was telling the
guys it kind of hurts my heart that we
don't like really get together for
dinner like very often at all you know
like and like and and I feel like it's
just uh it's so beautiful that we've had
this relationship for decades now that
we've here we are growing old together
and uh you know I want we're growing old
together we've become like more mature
better adjusted versions of ourselves
and I want us to be able to spend more
time and have more of a relationship
yeah yeah I I could do better in that
department for sure because I
never I never like I just like being
home with the kids and Emily and our
lousy dog bucket yeah um and I don't
want to say that we've not had a great
relationship because we have and uh you
know I brought my
my limited edition numbered print Aussie
Osborne oh you finally took the prize
tag off of it for years he just had the
picture on his wall with the prize tag
next to it well he said even before that
he just put tape on the wall and had it
hanging up in this the year I think was
uh 2005 or 2006 noxel says hey man I you
know I got you something and I go pick
it up at this address so I go into this
place there was kind of a non-descript
store I didn't even really know what it
was and I said hey you got something for
me and they they hand me this big uh
flat brown paper bag and I pull out of
it this print of aie Osborne oh wow
because Aussie was my hero I always said
like man I want a party like Aussie he
was so out of control such a maniac and
I want to like be that and uh pulled it
out I like oh this is cool and then I
look in the bag and there's the receipt
and and the receipt shows that the price
of the print was more than
$1,500 I was like Wow and it says right
on there like it's it's 21 of 90 in
existence this picture and I didn't even
frame it for you hey steo go pick up
your gift what an
ass poster tube I I brought her home to
my apartment at the time just grabbed a
piece of tape and just stuck it with no
frame I I just taped the the the print
to the wall and then right next to it I
taped the receipt that said 1,500 bucks
the W and then like shortly thereafter I
was on MTV Cribs and like like
highlighted it and like bragged about it
like here's the print and here's the
receipt so funny and you know what it
became like such a more beautiful thing
because I I I went on to learn that that
picture is was taken in
1974 of Aussie Osborne and it was taken
in London England and I was born in 1974
in London England like that photo was
snapped as I was yeah I knew
that the whole time but yeah just I mean
there's been things like that over the
years that that's Mick Rock right yeah
and he just passed away yeah do you like
shopping on Amazon I do and good news is
sto's butt wipes for your butthole are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get sto's
hot sauce for your butthole plus sto's
butthole destroyer and sto's butt wipes
for your butthole it's the butthole
bundle available on Amazon right
now yeah dude yeah